so you're a 51 year old woman who's been
with the same man for 20 years 21 years
so we can have an adult conversation
okay did you have sex with these two
inmates no I just figured your friends
in my friend that makes us friends
what's going on with you Attili maybe we
can arrange a get together soon I'm
cutting the pipe up doing the work all
you do is sleep nobody knows about a
marriage took the people in the marriage
and sometimes even they don't know so
you want to be part of my dream
yes
I want to be a part of your dream you
focus on something in your mind feel it
in your heart and you commit to it it
will come true
[Music]
but once their legs
[Music]
whatever you knew them to be while they
were in there they're in a lot different
circumstances now sure there's a dark
side but there's also very human side
did you ask her why she was giving that
me know I know we're in a gray area with
the meat wouldn't it be convenient to be
the only person who lives to tell the
story I didn't do anything wrong I mean
not really wrong
[Music]
you